[Music]
bush planes are designed to fly in and
out of remote areas they're engineered
to be able to take off and land on short
runways
they can also be outfitted with floats
to be able to land on water or skis to
land on snow
some are made of metal and others of
tube and fabric construction
[Music]
a bush plane starts out as a design on
paper this company handcrafts
four-seater tube and fabric models
the tubes forming the airplane skeleton
the fabric its skin
welders construct a tubular frame for
the fuselage the plane's main body the
tubes are chromoly a type of steel that
contains chromium and molybdenum which
makes it stronger than standard steel
machinists make the aluminum fuel tank
components
and prepare the landing gear
here they're threading the axle for the
tail wheel
a small rugged wheel at the back which
helps steer the airplane on the ground
the landing gear consists of this tail
wheel and two bigger wheels at the front
they all have large low pressure tires
which enable the plane to take off and
land on rough terrain
workers spray aluminum pieces called
ribs and spars with anti-corrosion paint
then rivet them together to build the
internal structure of the wings
using a crimping tool
they make tiny indentations in the ribs
to perfect the alignment
then they rivet on a skin of aluminum
panels about 1 50th of an inch thick in
most areas
they construct the wing's hinge surface
the flaps and ailerons the same way
the factory's paint shop sprays the
wings flaps and ailerons with highly
durable urethane paint and the fuselage
frame with powder coat paint which is
then baked on for extra durability
now for the meticulous job of applying
the fabric skin
the material is heat shrinkable
polyester
commonly used in the aircraft industry
because it's thin lightweight and
exceptionally strong
workers brush an adhesive similar to
contact cement onto the painted tubing
then adhere the fabric working around
the frame section by section
[Music]
once the fuselage is completely covered
they run a hot iron over the fabric this
shrinks it taut around the framework
after letting the adhesive dry for a
couple of hours they take strips of
fabric coat them with a urethane based
adhesive and reinforce the seams
it's the same construction process for
the tail components
at the front of the fuselage now they
install the pedals which control both
the brakes and the rudder which moves
the tail from right to left
then the cockpit instrument panel a thin
sheet of aluminum with laser cut
openings for all the flight
instrumentation
next two link control yokes
they move a series of chains which
maneuver certain components such as the
aileron control sprockets
mechanics run the fuel lines and most of
the wiring within the fuselage frame
prior to the fabric application
now they install a stainless steel
firewall between the cockpit and the
engine
this seals the cockpit from engine heat
noise and exhaust gases
after installing the landing gear brakes
and windshield workers mount the engine
and exhaust system
next the plane's aluminum propeller
other workers are busy installing the
fuel tanks inside the wings
the fuselage now goes to the paint shop
when it comes back workers bolt on the
wings supporting them from underneath
with steel wing struts
the wings on a bush plane are positioned
higher than those on other types of
aircraft to give the pilot better ground
visibility
[Music]
after rigging up the flight controls and
installing the interior trim
workers install the doors plexiglas
windows and cockpit seating
each bush plane is inspected at every
stage of the production process
when it's completed it undergoes a
nose-to-tail final inspection
and then a company pilot takes it out
for a test flight
[Music]
you